Well, Detective Hayes...
Could you tell us your timeline of events
April 7th 1980
It was just a case
Now I know it will be my last
Two kids supposed to be home by 5:30
Never Arrived
We almost had a clean night man
Anything to tell me about Will?
He's quite. I don't think he got noticed much
I'm telling you, they didn't run off
All you had to do was watch them!
Mind if we look around?
How you gonna wear that badge?
Got a little clip on it
You look like you haven't slept in a couple of days
I never stop coming up with theories about that case
In our job, there is no certainty
What you don't remember you don't know you don't remember
What?
Did you think you could just go on and never once have to look back
My whole brain is a bunch of missing pieces
You ever been some place you couldn't leave
You couldn't stay... Both at the same time
Things I have seen...
Things I know...
Wouldn't do anything but cause harm
Lots of people around this are dead
Lot of people gone
Most people I ever knew are gone
Whatever you think you did or didn't do,
You don't deserve to suffer
This case is all that I can think of
Now I wanna know the whole story